طب داخليه
في محاولات اسكات هذه الانتفاضه هل برايك
سيكون للعقوبات التي اعلن عنها الغرب ضد
ايران منذ بدايه الانتفاضه اي تاثير على
النظام وارادته في القمع
تؤثر هذه العقوبه على قدرته النظام على
اسكاتي
المتظاهرين
تطبق
وما دامت البلاد التي تفرض العقوبات غيرهم
واهتمه بيت التشاجره او الخصام على ايران
احاول تطبيق نظام العقوبات الحاليه فلا
اتوقع من العقوبات الجديده ان يكون لها اي
اثر كبير على النظام
في حال لو تغيرت طبيعه النظام كليا لنظام
عسكري هل يتغير في هذه الحاله دور المرشد
الاعلى كيف نتصور ان يكون دوره
المرشد الاعلى سيكون دور القائد الرمزيلي
الدوله
الرئيسه في المانيا او المستشار لديه
السلطه السياسيه الحقيقيه ولكن هذا هو
الدور الذي يتخيلهم للمرشد الاعلى
للمستقبل لايران او خليفه عن
اهويت خلفيه للمرشد الحالي همم
من ممكن ان يكون خليفه
او من سيصبح القائد الجديد الايراني
جدا تحت الظروف الحاليه ولكن لا اعتقد
بانه الاسم هو المهم او الخليفه هو المهم
الشيء الاهم هو اللي من هو مدين بهذا
المنصب من الذي سيجعله قائدا لايران وهذه
الجماعه ستتولى السلطه الحقيقيه